[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Mélissa Sebire et
je suis la fondatrice de la mode de
Mélissa aujourd'hui je suis là avec vous
pour vous partager des conseils mode et
on va commencer par quelques techniques
pour allonger votre silhouette
[Musique]
alors que vous soyez grande ou petite le
but c'est vraiment de vous donner des
conseils très très simple à mettre en
place et très simple à faire avec ce que
vous avez dans votre garde-robe pour que
vous ayez justement une silhouette qui
est beaucoup plus grande si vous voulez
prochainement acheter des pantalons il
faut savoir qu'il ne faut pas prendre
n'importe quoi si vous voulez allonger
votre silhouette je vous déconseille
fortement de prendre des pantalons
taille basse c'est pas très beau déjà ça
ne m'est pas en avant votre silhouette
et ça va venir casser la hauteur en fait
de de perception qu'on a de votre
silhouette et du coup vous allez faire
plus petite que prévu d'ailleurs que
vous soyez grand ou pas cette solution
là vous vous tassera en fait clairement
ces mots que je cherchais
donc l'idée c'est de prendre des
pantalons taille haute le plus haut
possible de façon à ce que ça arrive au
dessus de votre nombril parce que c'est
vraiment le centre en fait de votre de
votre silhouette et c'est lui qui est
extrêmement important pour vous galber
pour paraître plus grand plus mince etc
donc je vais vous montrer
l'idée c'est de prendre des pantalons
taille haute et de les positionner comme
je vous disais au dessus du nombril et
en fait naturellement votre taille va
être destinée et vous allez avoir
l'impression d'avoir des gens très très
grandes et voilà comment paraître plus
grande que prévu et la preuve en est on
pense toujours que je suis quelqu'un de
très très grande quand on regarde mes
vidéos alors que je ne fais que 1m56
voilà autre astuce aussi hyper simple à
rectifier très rapidement les trois
quarts du temps les jeans ou les
pantalons de manière générale ont un
certain standard et souvent les jambes
sont beaucoup trop grandes du coup ça
vous fait des espèces de plis ou de
gouttière vous voyez sur le bas du
pantalon et l'idée c'est de venir faire
un ourlet pour finalement couper le
vêtement le pantalon à votre taille il
n'y aura plus cet effet vous savez de
gouttière comme ça sur le bas du
pantalon vous aurez un effet droit comme
ici et en fait c'est ça qui va venir
aussi allonger votre silhouette
et voilà je vous ai donc donné quelques
petits conseils pour allonger votre
silhouette que vous soyez grande ou
petit et n'oubliez pas le but c'est que
vous vous sentiez bien dans votre corps
à bientôt
[Musique]